le labo à orléans
mam à toulon la c2 aussi à chartres
bourges ou encore bois depuis quelques
années ils poussent dans la région comme
des champignons
chaque métropole chaque agglomération a
désormais son incubateur un endroit où
tous les porteurs de projets innovants
les créateurs de start-up trouve sur
place
un coaching personnalisé et un réseau
professionnel
bienvenue dans le monde des entreprises
nouvelles générations
le labo à orléans accueille depuis 2015
dans d'anciens locaux industriels
une vingtaine de start up spécialisée
dans le numérique
oui si on est dans l'entrée dans le hall
du labo dans l'espace dans l'espace
convivialité
voyez il ya des machines à café il ya
des tables et un certain nombre de
choses qui qui permettent soit de
s'opposer pour boire un café discuter
c'est d'ailleurs souvent ou café que se
passe plein de choses entre les
entrepreneurs et puis aussi ça permet de
travailler tout simplement vient se
poser que son ordinateur peut même faire
des petites réunions de travail entre
entre collaborateurs voilà c'est
vraiment un lieu où beaucoup de choses
se passent comme working écoles de
développeurs espace de détente tout est
pensé pour faciliter les échanges à la
façon silicon valley jérôme richard élus
d'orléans métropole et ancien start peur
est l'un des cofondateurs du labo c'est
un lieu où à tout stade de projet qu'on
soit déjà une entreprise un peu avancé
ou alors simplement une idée on va vous
accompagner vous prendre en charge vous
aider à faire naître votre projet ou à
le faire grandir
et pour ça on a des structures
d'accompagnement on a un programme
d'accélération qui s'appelle saxo on a
aussi tout l'écosystème des
entrepreneurs qui ont déjà entrepris qui
sont des entrepreneurs plus ou moins
jeunes qui vont vous apporter leur
expérience vous évitez vous éviter des
ennuis
vous faire de façon bienveillante des
retours sur votre business model sur son
financement sur votre vision du marché
on a aussi tout un effet réseau puisque
au labo on a énormément de partenaires
on a créé des liens avec des partenaires
des grands groupes et des entreprises du
classique qui ont à la fois des besoins
en termes d'innovation mais n'ont pas
forcément l'agilité qui vont dire
chercher dans les entreprises et les
start-up de l'innovation mais aussi
qu'ils ont démarché à pourvoir qui ont
des réseaux à ouvrir jérôme le champion
et guillaume eberwein ont créé swaps un
gps qui localise les malades d'alzheimer
leur société vient tout juste d'intégrer
le labo en fait l'intérêt cet objet
c'est qu'il va géolocaliser tout le
temps en permanence il va suivre les
personnes il va aller traquer et minute
après minute on va pouvoir voir leurs
déplacements sur une carte
on va pouvoir définir un secteur de
promenade autour de la maison
un périmètre de vie et si la personne
n'est pas ce périmètre avec son
porte-clés on est directement prévenues
en tant qu'aidant l'application elle est
utilisable par le plus grand nombre
c'est à dire les enfants d'alzheimer son
conjoint ses voisins afin d'avoir une
véritable communauté des aidants qui va
pouvoir gérer une urgence en
s'installant à orléans les deux
fondateurs de swap espère profiter du
réseau professionnel du labo et cibler
le marché des collectivités de la région
ça nous a permis d'avoir un local dans
lequel ici on travaille avec jérôme pour
développer les nouvelles solutions
notamment celle ci qui est fait pour
géolocaliser en intérieur qui va
fonctionner à la fois comme un bracelet
aussi comme un clip comme un porte-clés
et dernièrement on est allé voir la
plupart des maisons de retraite qui sont
à orléans qui sont dans le bassin et on
est en train de mener en bonne voie pour
signer un contrat avec une maison de
retraite qui se trouve en riant
à l'instar de son homologue d'orléans
toute métropole a aussi créé son
incubateur il ya plus d'un an
mam ces quatorze mille mètres carrés
d'espacé dans un bâtiment industriel
classé à l'inventaire supplémentaire des
monuments historiques
l'endroit se veut en lien direct avec le
patrimoine la culture et le monde de
l'entreprise locale
l'objectif de mam c'est de démontrer que
la touraine est une terre de réussite on
peut venir étudier innover entreprendre
chercher investir en touraine et avec un
lieu qui un lieu très ouvert qui va
permettre un brassage
ici vous avez l'université vous avez la
chambre de commerce vous avez des start
up
vous avez aussi un fab lab vous avez des
associations voilà c'est un lieu qui
sera ouvert au public puisqu'il et
monuments historiques qui intéresse les
touristes qui intéresse les designers
voilà doc c'est à catalyseur de
l'énergie et de l'envié du territoire de
tours métropole de se développer
mam abrite un fab lab un laboratoire de
fabrication ouvert à tous il a aussi
développé un programme d' accélérateur
de start up le château ici on aide les
jeunes poussent à se lancer sur le
marché
en cinq mois seulement
dans ces cinq mois on va faire en sorte
de donner à l'entrepreneur un maximum de
ressources
deux méthodes d' expertise de mise en
relation pour pour faire pour faire
décoller son projet les premières
actions c'est d'aller faire confronter
l'idée le projet à la cible directement
en s'associant le labo et mam sont
devenus des lieux totem sous le label de
la french tech tour valais ils sont
rejoints petit à petit par d'autres
incubateur et bien peu par le c2i le
centre européen d'entreprise et
d'innovation de chartres géré par la cci
est aussi le seul à représenter un label
européen
le fait d'être européen ça permet à
n'importe quel start-up ici peut aller
rencontrer une autre start-up en
allemagne ou ou ailleurs
et donc c'était un réseau bon qui dit
réseaux dits facilité de discussion de
travailler ensemble et cetera on
travaille vraiment au niveau européen et
donc quand le plus on est nombreux en
réseau et plus c'est facile de trouver
les bons partenaires est une application
de trousse de beauté virtuel un réseau
communautaire gratuit directement on
arrive sur nos trousses thématiques et
en explorant fait les trousses on les
découvre
ben voilà les les produits que chaque
trousse renferme on se remet en selle
sur ces produits potentiellement on
passe à l'achat en intégrant le sait 2e
i j rémy cazals a non seulement accès au
réseau européen mais il se rapproche
aussi des entreprises de produits
cosmétiques
on a jugé stratégique de venir sur
chartres d'une pour pour avoir des
interlocuteurs qu'ils étaient motivés
parce que s'il ya un vrai qu'au système
autour des start up c'est aussi charte
pour son réseau cosmétiques donc ici il
ya ce qu'on appelle la cosmetic valley
la biotech qui voilà qui sont vraiment
des pôles dédiés au projet cosmétiques
donc ils nous ont beaucoup aidés jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
chaque incubateur à développer sa
spécificité
celui de bourges s'est orienté vers les
étudiants entrepreneurs des partenariats
on développe de plus en plus notamment
avec l'école d'ingénieurs qui est juste
à côté l insa centre val de loire
on souhaite développer encore plus de
relations avec l'enseignement secondaire
sur l'agglomération de bourges et aussi
avec la chambre de commerce et avec tous
les acteurs économiques du territoire
qui peuvent accélérer toutes les
démarches pour les porteurs de projets
pierre hautecoeur est en alternance
en parallèle de ses études il porte un
projet de vente d'insectes destiné aux
bars à thème là vous avez des grillons
chorizo parmesan par exemple qui
seraient vendues sur un réseau de
distribution comme des bars ambiance
plus le site internet de la marque
je viens travailler ici et donc
gratuitement j'ai accès aux locaux 24
heures sur 24 qui me permettent donc de
développer mon projet et à savoir aussi
que je suis pas tout seul à travailler
sur ce projet ce que je travaille
également avec
les étudiants des promotions maxi de
bouche tu sais festubert curien où je
suis en cours pour mon alternance les
start up se lance sur le marché de
l'innovation un marché émergent alors il
faut faire vite car les idées peuvent
partir ailleurs le conseil régional l'a
bien compris en tout cas on est obligé
de s'adapter on avait des dispositifs
d'accompagnement auprès des entreprises
on a vu qu'on avait des entreprises qui
avaient des modèles économiques un peu
différent donc il a fallu qu'on on
adapte nos dispositifs de soutien on
adapte nos critères d'analysé pour
pouvoir apprécier ces entreprises et là
sur le chaque année on accompagne une
cinquantaine d'entreprises ce qui montre
que vraiment on s'est dit c'est concret
quoi on sait 5 millions d'euros qui sont
mobilisés pour l'ensemble de
l'accompagnement des start-up développe
est une association créée par le conseil
régional
elle a pour mission d'apporter une aide
logistique aux entreprises et porte une
attention particulière aux start-up
antoine valls est chargé de les
accompagner
[Musique]
m
notamment sur les salons internationaux
comme par exemple le cs de las vegas aux
états unis un salon consacré à
l'innovation technologique en
électronique grand public
ça va à dieu de l'hébergement au
transport de l'organisation sur le salon
de donner tout de faire le garde fous
entre guillemets c'est à dire de mettre
en garde les entreprises les start up
sur ce qu'il faut faire pour que le
salon ils soient rentables et pour
qu'ils puissent maximiser leur présence
sur le salon et donc on va s'occuper
aussi la logistique de la réservation de
l'espace de l'aménagement esthétique et
tout à tous les aspects communication
c'est des aspects aussi qu'on va pouvoir
gérer pour in fine et faire en sorte que
l'entreprise elle a vraiment à se
consacrer que à sa recherche de
distributeurs de clients d'investisseurs
cette année 10 start up de la région
fait partie du voyage dont jeanne a
sense qui propose un système de capteurs
numériques met au point pour aider à
mieux vieillir chez soi
les capteurs sont placées un peu partout
dans les pièces de vie aujourd'hui
antoine bien faire le bilan avec michael
alves le fondateur de la start up
on a eu également d'excellents retours
sur la partie techno et sur des dérivés
possible autour de ça donc on a on n'a
au final pas mal de pistes à explorer
pour cette année et avec l'optique d'y
retourner l'an prochain avec accor l
étape de franchie vraiment développe ça
nous apparaît ça vraiment fait citer
toute la partie logistique et puis en
effet l'intérêt d'aller au cv c'est que
ça permet de se confronter
à tout ce qui se passe en fait dans le
monde en termes de projets en termes de
d'acteurs d'acteurs business et les voir
et les voir quelque part passé s'arrêter
devant nous et d'écouter ce qu'ils ont à
nous dire donc et de voir un petit peu
les sollicitations et en l'occurrence on
en a eu d'assez nombreuses venant
directement de des états unis et de
l'asie du pacifique à 15,6 dans le cher
en plein coeur du vignoble françois et
pierre christophe ont installé leur
entreprise ils ont mis au point un
système de surveillance des vignes par
drone un outil très utile aux
viticulteurs notamment en cas d'épisode
météorologiques comme le gel qui a sévi
au printemps 2010 est en fait le gel il
va retarder le départ de la végétation
donc les endroits qui ont gelé on va
voir si on attend un petit peu que la
végétation a pas du tout démarré et on
va voir des contrastes quand on va
regarder justement les cartes que je
vous montre ses deux zones dans la
parcelle sur lesquelles on va avoir plus
de vert que deux rouges sont les zones
qui ont été protégés où la vigne a pu se
développer et on voit al'inverse quand
on regarde par exemple sur le bas de la
parcelle qui n'était pas du tout protégé
en fait les vignes ont pas du tout
démarré parce qu'elles ont été j'ai donc
là quel est l'intérêt à la fois de
maîtriser de comprendre le taux de
protection mais aussi et surtout
optimiser le disque de la position des
système antigel les jeunes entrepreneurs
sont passés par l'incubateur de bourges
depuis septembre 2017
ils ont intégré la pépinière sans l'aide
de l'incubateur françois et pierre
christophe n'aurait jamais pu se lancer
ça a été une grande aide ça nous a
permis d'intégrer en fait une communauté
dans laquelle on échange
delà de l'information des savoir faire
etc et donc ça le projet n'aurait pas pu
se monter sur l'intégration du
technopole ces dernières années les
incubateurs sont devenus les
accélérateurs incontournable de création
d'entreprises innovantes une
accélération nécessaire pour capter des
marchés internationaux en pleine
explosion
prochain objectif pour la région et les
métropoles intégrer le label french tech
gage du savoir faire français
une carte de visite indispensable pour
s'exporter
mais aussi pour attirer de nouvelles
activités sur le territoire